es una nueva promesa de Lula da Silva a
los pueblos indígenas de Brasil de
marcar más tierras indígenas lo antes
posible proceso que se estancó durante
el mandato del ultraderechista Jair
bolsonaro tras prometer a No demarcar ni
un centímetro más
ocupando los indígenas no están ocupando
la tierra de nadie solo están luchando
por lo que era suyo y que Los Invasores
desde 1500 les han ido quitando
Trozos de tierra que les pertenecía a
ustedes
en la amazonía es común que se surpe en
tierras indígenas para deforestarlas y
sacar beneficio económico con
actividades como minería ilegal o
ganadería para después reclamarlas como
propias con documentos falsos algo que
ha perjudicado e incluso les ha costado
la vida a los Indígenas pero también al
mayor bosque húmedo del mundo así lo
indica yoenia guapichana presidenta de
la fundación Nacional de los pueblos
indígenas la razón es sencilla una de
sus principales misiones es cuidar y
respetar la naturaleza
a pesar de haber sufrido todos estos
años de persecución y de parálisis
política las tierras indígenas siguen
siendo las que cuentan con mayores
índices de preservación de los bosques y
son las que están más protegidas de la
deforestación
Yo es que a pesar de los esfuerzos del
ejecutivo de Lula da Silva la amazonía
brasileña ha vuelto a batir un récord en
deforestación en febrero con un 62% pero
si se aumentan las reservas ambientales
que ocupan el tres de coma siete del
territorio brasileño donde viven unos
800.000 indígenas podría proteger a los
pueblos originarios y al Bosque a la vez